yellow welcome to new video this will be
a yeah new thing for this channel I
decided to do something else and what
I'm going to do is some yeah and do a
book review um I really like to buy and
study young chess books um a lot
actually
and maybe yeah you can say more than
that's really necessary for training
proposes um but yeah I just like to read
new stuff and yeah I get to know ideas
that people propose and books um
yeah I'm going to start with a book that
I've recently purchased I think you know
two or three weeks ago it's also a
pretty new book just just released um
it's an it's an opening book an opening
repertoire book actually and it's um
doesn't focus on one specific opening
but actually has to go to present a
complete repertoire for both white and
black so it's um basically a complete
guide to to your whole yeah opening
spectrum with both colors um I think
it's some it's a very very good book and
really does a good job of presenting
everything that some yeah basically
necessary to play those openings it's
about 500 pages total I'm not I didn't
do a count but it's around 500 pages and
it's called the Kaufman repertoire for
black and white or white and black got
two titles actually for black and white
it's always black and white
um and it's um is written by Larry
Kaufman's the authors Grandmaster
Kaufman so the coffin repertoire
first to the author's name um yeah a few
words about the author maybe because
he's some most probably not so well
known um
he's some international Grandmaster and
he's got the child a couple of years ago
by becoming the world champion for for
senior players about sixty if you win
the world senior championship you'll get
the Grandmaster gee I'd love in one go
so it's not the matter of getting norms
and rating and so on just with the
tourney and get the title but it's a
well-deserved title because the world
Senior Championships is really a tough
tournament if you look at this um
there's a ton of grandmasters and
international masters granted there
they're not um he added on you don't
have your dynamic 15 year olds but it's
a wealth of experience and really strong
chest knowledge throughout so well
deserved
um title for the author here yeah so
he's in his early 60s as you can guess
by by this sadly one and he's got a huge
experience um also in computer chess
he's worked a couple of years for the
rib karting developing yeah one of the
strongest chess engines and working on
I think it's opening book and also
evaluation functions so it's got a
background not only in chess but also in
IT is a program as well and so he relies
heavily in this book on computer
analysis you can at least be sure that
every line has been checked with engines
so you can be can be assured that there
are no or there shouldn't be of course I
cannot check everything there shouldn't
be any gross technical mistakes or
anything in them and once in a while you
need to get used to somewhat computer is
evaluations in the book
sometimes their statements like okay
whites 1/2 pound half porn ahead or
something and okay
why does somewhat better would be my
translation to to human language but he
summarized some yeah very much in this
commuter to computer terms so okay but
it's it's no big deal um I think what
I'd like to do is to go quickly through
the recommendations so that you can see
what kind of lines he proposes very
often it's um that it's the case that
you don't really want to copy everything
that is recommended in such a book but
maybe pick out a couple of lines that
you like and see those lines as a
starting point for your repertoire
that's also the reason why I got this
book maybe the target audience is some
yes more yeah it's it's not really my
level of play let's say but they're
couple of a couple of lines in there
that I'd like to study or try to learn
in the future and it's a very good yeah
reference for form for starting out to
to play on those lines okay let's go
quickly through his recommendations I
think I start with the white side it's a
lot to to go through and with white he
proposes one D form and of course this
invites me to make some quick
comparisons to my own quick repertoire
that I did in a couple of videos if you
haven't watched this yet if you play d4
or interested in playing D form I made
15 videos for the white side of d4 so
check those out that's in there good
good starting point for working out your
repertoire okay let's let's start with
d5 of course he goes for the Queen's
Gambit he gives some a browse for a book
and just quote what's what's in there
basically first of all he goes through
some rail lines in the Queen's Gambit
like chigorin defense or second bishop
chickering's 9600 Bishop f5 yeah the
Albans all those defenses are yeah more
or less playable or dubious and he gives
I think quite convincing lines against
them um it's a pretty much identical to
the stuff that I gave in my videos the
next one on e6 the the classical Queens
gambit he proposes Knight c3 under
Knight f6 exchange just like I did in my
video and this is no surprise as it is
yeah just the strongest line basically
on Bishop e7 he also wants to exchange
and play Bishop f4 this is also
identical to to my recommendation but no
surprises I think the most testing and
that's a logical choice he gives um what
else can like play on the tirage here
he gives whoops roof across 95 he gives
unsurprisingly the main line and then he
proposes this this variation which is
rare but getting popular it's very very
poisonous line for black I recently
played this in the German um Club cap
and scored a quick win with white as
black really didn't know how to respond
and I got got an overwhelming position
not quickly the tirage is not not so
critical for white but of course it's um
it's it's played rather often at least
on a known ya amateur level
on the sloth see 6 p.m. here Scott oops
he's got two lines actually he the one
hand he's got the main line here with 93
so he allows taking here and then a four
on Bishop f5 95 yeah I think this is the
most critical line as well I gave this
in my videos as also there are a couple
of interesting proposals though lines
that I didn't know and where he also
suggests a couple of yeah improvements
on existing theory theory of course I'm
heavily checked with with computer
analysis on a six here he gives up soon
he gives a for you six to three which is
it's interesting I didn't have this in
my videos but it's a it's a it's a
tricky line so a good choice I think on
hoops on e6 same is love he gives Bishop
g5 was just of course the heavy body of
theory because the last bit Vinick
variation here which is very very
complicated he gives a good outline of
them of the main lines it's it's
considered a bit dubious for black
anyway but for this really super sharp
lines I think the coverage in the book
is of course limited due to to size
restrictions so if you allow this as
white I think you need to maybe do a
little bit more studying than this book
at least if you face some strong
opposition on h6 here he mainly proposes
the solid line here which has been
played with success by amongst cars and
recently he
things white gets a small edge yeah
maybe he does it's a it's not easy to
get this edge but this is some decent
choice as Bishop H for this anti Moscow
gambit is really completely unclear and
very tough to cover in such a book he
also gives an only alternative here in
the Slav Quincy to which i think is a
good a good idea he caught us the lazy
man's answer to the Slav which is some
yeah fitting because it's it's a pretty
good line which still previous preserves
some chances for our phone advantage for
white but is really playable with very
few variations you have to have to learn
mostly it it goes this way and then
white can kettle's the bishop and later
tries to play for e to e for after
thorough preparation this is a good line
I always had this as some sort of
reserve line because I always thought
okay you can always play this and you
don't need to know so much about it and
so get get a playable position where you
can try for offer a bit of an advantage
so I think this is all in only good a
good choice here and the Cape in the
Queens gambit on 9f 66 he mainly
concentrates on the nihms oh and gives
Queen c2 which is arguably the main line
yeah I think he did some some decent
coverage there um twin si tube it's a
solid positional line or white avoids
any pawn structure deficits here or so
no double pawns and the only Star Trek
is that white um somewhat delays his
development of the king side so it's a
line where you
you get the nice strategic edge but
where you need to be careful not to fall
to behind in development but it's it's a
decent recommendation of course in my
repertoire videos I went for f3 here for
three with just a lot sharper and also
very often leads to this messy pawn
structure with Bishop c3 but it very
much fit to to the other choices so I
think f3 is also a valid move that's an
alternative here he also outlines
quickly Knight f3 because some a lot of
players don't like to face the news Oh
so um this um he also gifts with some
nice lines against the Queen's inion
mostly this one which is a tricky line
we should be sixes flex mailings
nowadays and here he shows briefly
Bishop f4 which is also nice try for an
advantage um he's got some move order
ideas here castles
thank you plays rook c1 which is
directed against the knight bg7 lineups
the 9 PT 7 line which recently got very
popular so is really on top of yeah
current theory here I think all in all
these suggestions are a very valid and
and playable what else is there on the
Benko which this is interesting I think
in my repertoire of videos I proposed b6
here to return the pawn he recommends
something entirely different
I just got ba 6
accepting the pawn and oops
Bishop g7 g3 so it goes for the for the
classical mainline and here h3 is the
main move or even a rookie one and here
it proposes a brand-new move a four and
claims that white can play for an
advantage
the idea is to quickly establish this
outposts ground beef I've to try to yeah
stop flex play on the queenside
I didn't check this yet I have to admit
I only saw that she recommends it it's
really new I never saw this move before
so but this is also interesting
you can if you can dig out moves that I
haven't been played a lot and study it
in this book or maybe add some some own
ideas and analysis then this can be a
really strong weapon it's always a good
idea to to get to get new ideas and and
play this in your games to surprise the
opponent I just saw that I am completely
skipped one Queen's Gambit line sorry
they accepted and there it gives two
lines before as I also I did this in my
videos as well that's the most testing
and there's an alternative he proposes I
think in this move order for people who
like to do risk free pressing this dc5
line which is arguably a bit timid but
it's not quite clear if black is really
100% equal here um for instance magnus
carlsen recently or recently it's about
half a year ago I think last summer
he scored a very convincing win against
strong Grandmaster Nyssa piano from
Romania and he won rather quickly I
think 30 moves or some
and this is a nice risk free alternative
to tui form if you want a quiet game
where you can still do some pressing
what else D for an f5 the Dutch it's got
an interesting recommendation on in my
videos I'm not quite sure what and what
I recommend it
I think g3 after all yeah I think so
Bishop g5 versus missus proposed line
and this is indeed interesting um it's
somewhat somewhat rare line but it's not
obscure something it's for instance has
been played a couple of years ago by a
Kasparov so it's certainly a solid line
the idea of this move is simply to work
yeah prevent black from plainy six by
just pinning the c7 pawn and and I don't
have six is most likely to yeah will be
captured and it will be captured if
black plays it instantly because it's
just just a bad pawn structure and if
black plays something like g6 um he has
to reckon with h4 not in this position I
think one or two moves later but that's
the general idea a very nice feature of
this line is that it leads to somewhat
young unusual positions if black for
instance heads for four for this
leningrad set up with Knight f6 g6 and
so on okay this is over now
like I cannot get into this and he will
have to face a completely different
setup um on d6 and oops on g6 he wants
to play a form which is also identical
to my video I also recommended this and
he goes form for Bishop III lines here I
think I I didn't recommend something
specifically
but it's just a matter of taste just
pick one line study event most likely
you'll have chances to play for for some
advantage against the perk of modern I
think I mainly went for a four year but
I didn't show it and it should be three
of courses you know one of the main
lines
besides f/4 and it's a good line so I'm
it's a decent recommendation yeah of
course he also has got some ideas
against those offbeat stuff like
Budapest or others he's got an
interesting a recommendation in the
Benoni she liked to show moves water
doesn't matter he plays another three
system anyway he recommends we should
their form and this is I think really
maybe an underestimated system on an
amateur level most amateur players just
play a four here and we should be force
a very poisonous
line it's it's played regularly if he's
got the chance
the noni is not played so often on top
level by eleven or onion until for
instance recently scored a very nice
when against Magog Ashima who's pretty
much the only regular benoni players and
among the top words top players there
was a very nice win by Boris Gelfand
recently a couple of month ago so Bishop
f4 it's a very very good line I think
and also line where it's um it's it's
probably the case that black doesn't
know it so well compared to compared to
other other variations here
yeah the King's Indian was the King's
Indian he proposes the classical
variation with Bishop e2 and here this
is of course the most critical setup he
he proposes two lines his main proposal
is to
to go here for this yeah so called
Korchnoi line with 91 Bishop III which
is of course a really tough test of the
Kings Indian and now he goes
Roxy one um he's very very optimistic
about why chances he and yeah he's at
one point even thought that yeah sort of
refutation of the classical Kings Indian
with 96 which is probably yeah not too
far off it looks it's looking really
grim for black from a theoretical point
of view but if you have played this kind
of lines from the white side you know
that you will get mated you'll get made
it anyway even if you get a nice
position and it's everything's fine
black will have counter play a lot of
counter play he will most likely lose
material on the Queen side and so on but
still he will have from ya cheatin
chances let's say um so this is really a
good recommendation from a theoretical
point of view but it's a very wise that
he has got a back up line included and
this is Bishop III here which is yeah
also maybe an underestimated line and
this leads to positions where white aims
for a very slight advantage but it's
quite comfortable to play the
theoretical antidote is supposed to be
rook e8 very just exchanges and plays h3
if I'm not wrong this is indeed a line
which looks very equal at first sight
but it's somewhat dangerous for black so
it's a it's a good idea to to study this
this line on Bishop Nagi form Bishop g5
also might be a slightly better for
white it's it's not a try for for
refutation as the other line with 91
Bishop e3
Kershner setup but to try to get a
decent position with slight advantage
and not so much risk involved so we've
got two nice alternatives of course he
also gives lines against the other tries
not bt 796 and so on but these are not
so critical and from a theoretical point
of view why should always be able to try
for somewhat slight advantage them and
he basically relies on the main lines so
these are good odds also a very very
fine choice um ya know of the goon fault
which is important of course as it is
very popular and also interesting to
look at here because the Grune fault is
part of his black recommendation so at
this point the white and black sides
overlap a bit and funny enough he goes
for the Russian system with Queen B 3
which I also had recommended this is
nothing mostly a coincidence yeah and
oops of course not before and he is
pretty clear in his statement that the
only line that he thinks that gives
black equality or close to equality is
the a six line the Hungarian variation
with the p5 he thinks all other lines
like we should be 496 white can try for
for some advantage yeah I didn't look at
at all specific single lines but I think
there's yeah there's a grain of truth in
there as a six is by far the most
popular booth among top players
I think they there are almost no I think
there's no player that regularly goes
for four other moves than a six Peter
Svidler for instance the world's leading
expert on the green fund I think he
always plays Essex at least in recent
games that I can remember
at the end of the this a six line this
is identical in the white and black part
of the repertoire there is state that
you think that white has a slight
advantage but black has counter chances
I think this is a fair assessment so
it's a play with positions for a play
with position for both side after all
you will have this issue all the time
unless you play something totally
offbeat on one side like one before or
something when you're pretty sure that
no one will ever play before against you
but if you play mainland opening you
left this kind of overlap of white and
black all the time yeah all in all I
think a very decent recommendations
there are yeah pretty solid no super
aggressive sharp lines that maybe we'll
get refuted or something they're all all
to test it and good and still offer some
chances for advantage I think white
players who who play one d4 or
interested in playing one d4 and we will
have some nice study material here it
some really young recommended he also
did a small chapter not not a lot I
think about 20 pages or 15 pages on
Knight f3 which is not he didn't do this
in detail he just says that lots lots of
the lines that he recommends also can
rise from 93 this is true of course D 5
D 4 you will get Queen's Gambit lines
that he also covers or night oops Knight
f3 Knight f6 black and always go for
Kings Indian and so on so he gives a
little bit of information about the pros
and cons if white would like to play
Knight f3 and uses as a transposition of
tool two lines that are covered in the
book
I think this is a nice nice bonus there
by myself I really always plain idea
three so um yeah this is what's of some
value for me as well okay this is the
white side I hope I didn't forgot some
some major major opening where you might
like to know what is recommending but I
think I I got it all
okay now not about the black side also
reverse the board here with black yeah
he gives out a motto for his choices in
this called magnus carlsen defenses so
it says basically he goes for the lines
that cards in place which is funny
because yeah cards and almost play he
plays almost any opening but okay maybe
the ones he chose eyes main choices may
be true yeah let's start with one
default and then he recommends the room
felt he also gives recommendations of
course for side lines like I don't know
the London or anything and I think they
have a decent decent lines not risky
ones once where you can try to get a bit
of play against the oftentimes somewhat
down setups yeah in the green third of
course yeah the main line ups is the is
the exchange here in the Bishop c4 nine
which is arguably the the main line of
the whole opening he gives different
options here Queen c7 also is six
it was pretty new to me that this move
even existed and also briefly b6
which has been the main choice recently
off of top players yeah it's very
largely that this variation will come up
often so it's nice to have two or three
alternatives in general the room felt is
rather yeah theory heavy opening you
need to know really some specific lines
so if you only have this book you should
really yeah maybe consider what kind of
opposition you're facing if you think
that your opponents are really good
theoretically maybe it's an idea to to
get some more detailed coverage maybe
but it's it's really what he did in the
in the yeah amount of space that he had
this is very good um on on Knight f3
here rook b1 which is also dangerous
line he gifts he gives this Bishop d2
takes takes and now b6 which differs
from other recommendations that have
been made and yeah the standard work on
the groom felt now from Boris a brush
less last year this really Grandmaster
he did a more than 1000 page work on the
green card to two books I think it
should be 1000 pages with you if you add
this up or maybe 900 or something but
really a huge huge amount of theory this
would be the recommendation if you would
like to play the groom that regularly
and think you've got really super strong
opposition then these kind of books will
get you one level higher so the same ok
b6 is one line and the other one which i
think is also good that he gives you
this Knight see
and mainline it goes like this and then
Bishop c7 somewhat weird but this is a
tested line and also I think who came
from like on this here
he gives the the standard lines oops
with Queen a5 and then worked the eight
next also the choice of the top layers
at the moment in general the goon Feltes
maybe legs main answer on the top one
when master level nowadays on deform and
like it's very fine theoretically so you
will have lots of yeah new games to her
to check out if you decide to play the
groom felt as I mentioned on the Russian
if online here he considers a six to be
the only really good one so of course he
recommends it on Bishop f4 he goes form
c5 just usual lines
I think if white doesn't go for the CD
five lines which are the most aggressive
on all other stuff like the should g5f
for and III and so on
the books are I have this average book
and have another blue third book and
recommendations are very similar sorry
very similar for the for the non main
line so to say because basically black
doesn't have so so big problems there
and the main lines have been worked out
for years so the books are very similar
in this respect yeah what else is there
it says something really
remarkable what he recommends yeah a
funny recommendation on f3 which is
which is an interesting try for y2 to
steer the game away from usual channels
um the idea is to go for you for here
and don't give black and knight on c3
that he can capture and this uh black
needs to go Knight b6 here it's I think
ok for black but it's not to everybody's
taste
he gives knight c6 which is somewhat
funny move the idea is on e4 to go E 5
and it leads to quite interesting
positions it's not completely offbeat
for instance Peter Svidler I mentioned
him already a couple of times has played
this as well I think more than once
every of course is not played so often
on top level so you won't have no it
doesn't games to study but he played
this I think I think that is twice so it
should be should be okay yeah okay
that's that's a goon felt and of course
he does the other lines on deform okay
what he's got on c4 well c4 he plays g6
which is an interesting choice
but it's it's very decent very decent
choice he argues that on Knight c3 black
will go c5 it had four symmetrical
English where white has already four
faded the most aggressive options with
94 this is very true it's a good line
which is also funny enough it's been a
favorite of Bobby Fischer's fish' very
often answered c4 was g6 he was also
Gunsan player and on 93 of course c5
of course white goes deform Knight f6 we
worked on the way to the moon felt on
Knight f3 he goes 9 f6 and goes for d5
later this also could come up after
Knight f3 Knight f6 c4 g6 of course on
e4 which could be a strong argument
against this move he's um yeah he came
up with a really interesting line if I
if this has been played a couple of
times recently also by by top players
the idea is if white goes to Knight f3
you go Bishop g7 and this kind of
position here is very interesting the
idea is that black doesn't play d6 but
goes for c6 and d5 in one move here so
not D 6 D 5 as it is done often in the
King's Indian but d5 in one move this is
a very interesting line while white even
needs to be careful not to be worse if
he plays correctly you can I don't know
maybe maybe it's equal but certainly
nothing well white can play for an
advantage so the critical test here is
default and there he goes night-night f6
which leads to really wide tactical play
takes takes and Bishop b4 to come yeah
very interesting 9 I never really knew
that this existed and so I'm interesting
try and almost certainly a surprise for
for the opponent
so all these moves move order stuff here
is covered one thing which I found
interesting personally is that here he
recommends this line which I also didn't
you I knew that it existed but
and this is really an interesting very
solid option black goes for Knight Queen
d7 Bishop h3 to exchange the bishop and
then develop Bishop h9 h6 f5 later you
don't want to play h5 or something you
cannot made white here but this is an
interesting try I didn't know that this
is really am yeah so fine for black yeah
so this way he's got c4 nicely covered
on Knight f3 of course he he goes this
way and then transpose into the anti
green felt here he covers White's most
here Queen a4 and so on and gives decent
lines black is some usually okay in the
anti green felt he needs to know his
stuff it's a dangerous line but it's
it's nicely nicely covered him he also
gives an offbeat alternative here which
I found funny b6 I didn't know this at
all the ideas to play this way and now
go for for the double V and shadow here
this being the main line and this is
funny enough plate has been played by a
couple of good grandmasters mostly in in
open tournaments too yeah to get some
more lively positions compared to two
other lines and it's yeah seems to be
playable but this is just um just yeah
short short recommendation or idea here
for black okay now we go for four if all
its course and there you recommend some
to go one e5 um and he aims for the
ruler pests of Brea Spanish opening main
line and then on the ninth move from the
Brea variation with Knight b8 which is
indeed one of Magnus Carson's favorite
lines yeah one in five yeah I played
this myself so this was also one reason
why I got this book because he's got all
the other lines covered like the Italian
game or scotch and so on yeah lots of
players shy away from playing e5 because
they think it's so much theory all these
old lines and they get people who play
gambits and so on yeah I always thought
this as well right before I really took
a close look and started to play e5 of
course there are all these lines like
the scotch Italian and also those
gambits but yeah it is there is a reason
that almost all world-class players play
the ruler pest because yeah simply all
the other stuff isn't too dangerous
for black so you need to know your your
lines and it's not so much and you'll be
fine anyway and everywhere you know what
does he recommend first first start with
some risks to the crazy stuff the King's
gambit he recommends here d5
takes and takes on f4 this is yeah sort
of the no-nonsense approach it's no
trifling refutation like like taking for
instance Knight f3 and g5 is which is
also fine of course but d5 I think it's
a very sensible choice because it it
avoids all the really crazy lines um
black just goes for this is one main
line for for quick development and very
often he also gets a bishop pair because
white liquidate this Knight
25 with the bishop a good recommendation
and also very very easy to play you need
to know close to no lines here this is a
difference to Knight f3 g5 which is
really very heavy and okay yeah of
course there's the offbeat stuff Knight
c3 and so on but this is all fine for
black he gives the standard stuff there
which is recommended I don't know for 30
years and always has been fine for black
and will be on the Italian game here he
gives Bishop c5 just the main lines
which are really ok for blank he also
states that he considers this somewhat
difficult for black yeah I do agree I
played this a couple of times also and
these kind of lines are difficult to
play for black oh yeah they are not easy
for white either but Bishop c5 is
arguably the most solid choice and here
usually you get this kind of position
but I think I even plays castles here
and not a six yeah okay but this this is
just just okay for black here outlines
the main main lines there the Scotch is
always an interesting thing to look at
because here black has really two main
moves Bishop c5 and nine f6 Bishop c5
has been the main line for a couple of
years but it's now somewhat out of
fashion because of this year and he also
gives this as the reason why it doesn't
recommend Bishop c5 so he goes for 9006
and here in the main line he goes Knight
b6 which is an interesting choice
because Bishop a6 lately
yeah received more coverage and
was maybe believed to be the better move
but okay this has been played back
ramnik also and he also introduced on 93
which was thought to be the most
dangerous he introduced the new idea
Bishop d7 and quit castling and this
indeed looked very nice for black so a
good interesting recommendation what
else does he have an interesting thing
here here in the four Knights with
Bishop b5 he goes for Bishop c5 which
surprised me because this mover I didn't
have such a good reputation because of
those kind of lines Wendy for I always
thought that white would be just better
here but there have been a couple of
improvements for for black so this is
interesting it's also a lot less to
learn compared to Knight d4 this should
be fun okay let's go to the the Roy the
main line he goes a six of course on the
way to the brown on the exchange you
recommend this line and you think so
this is yeah he's sometimes very direct
in his evaluation so that this is the
only line that really promises black
full equality yeah I don't think so I
think black has lots of choices against
the exchange but okay this is a decent
line so it's it's fine just for status
black white cannot win win win here
please because this is made on the edge
file okay this is the exchange
recommendation and yeah here on the way
to to the Brea main line he of course
goes through all the different lines
white might shoes
which are mostly not too dangerous but
black nose should know his stuff Queeny
to d3 but all these lines are are not
yeah you don't need to invest hours to
study them you just need to look at one
set up and then you you're fine
of course rupee one is the main move and
here white has two choices h3 and is by
far the main move on d4 before it's not
played so often and he goes for the
usual Bishop g4 and thinks that this is
is equal yeah okay this is maybe true I
found it interesting that ambition b3
here he goes for this d5 line
I always opted for 95 and c5 but this is
an interesting alternative of course
yeah on h3 by far the main rules he goes
for the brayer they should not be 8 it's
always funny to just retreat the knight
and the idea is to reroute it to d7
where it is really better posted than on
c6 this allows um like to use the C pawn
off with c5 sometimes a blank also just
plays c6 and uses this kind of Philidor
setup or hen mm set up the brayer is an
excellent theoretical shape nowadays and
is played by really a lot of top players
Carlin is just one of them but the
brayer is also played by him
let's by Anand by all kinds of top
grandmasters so um yeah you I'm just
browsing through the book I got you got
your Kamsky on the black side or who
else do we have here Navarro
yeah it's just it's it's really one of
the best openings black and plain ss5 in
general of course the Fife is arguably
the the main line on rent master level
on top top Grandmaster never let's say
top top 30 40 or something yeah this is
pretty much everything outlined in the
book of course he also has some
recommendations against before b3 and so
on
so basically everything is covered yeah
all in all I can really heavily
recommend this book and Scott it really
has got lots of content um
pressed into those 500 pages um what you
need to do is keep depending on on your
own level of play is check which lines
you can play just with this book or do
you need some more information I would
say that up to a level of easily 2000 or
2100 the kind of depth presented in this
kind of book here it's easily enough to
play the opening if you are a lot above
that let's say for me personally am I've
got 2,400 and once in a while play
against Grand Master's I would really I
need some a little bit more information
on the lines but they're really good
starting points and he also gives lots
of nice hints and recommendations in the
text where he explains briefly okay this
line I chose this line because the other
two lines have this and that problem or
this and this issue so you can also dig
a bit for yourself so see if you agree
with his assessment and then maybe just
choose something else okay yeah thanks
for watching this really long video I
didn't expect it
we so long at the end and also I'm very
much would welcome feedback on the idea
of doing this kind of book reviews um
yeah usually I would just recommend a
book it doesn't make much sense for me
to to make a review of the bad book so
yeah I would be very interested to hear
if you would like more for of book
reviews
I wouldn't I know do this every week or
something but just once in a while if I
think there's it's a good book that is
of interest to lots of players then I
would I would do one yeah thanks for
watching and see you soon with new
content